i love how dudes is rating us now dude
dudes are just
raiding us they say all every time dude
every dude we've got a bunch of uh we're
gonna start a segment now where we
uh rank people what you know
go to uh find the kid uh instagram chin
fire guinness around yeah they put on
the story
you're writing them dudes yeah so people
can submit a picture of their friends
their girls
them whoever they want
or family and give a little background
to the fighter and the kids shop at
gmail.com or you can dm
the firing the kid instagram and we'll
see
it there too if you want to be future on
the show
yeah that's the way to do it they've
been rating us
do they rate you do they say all the
time oh yeah they're all the time you're
saying
they say to you though yeah like you
well they said he's consistent they're
like people
we were honest i like how he quickly
turned away
are they being nice to you are people
like john you're good
hey man you come to west virginia you
were 15.
makes yeah they say like the most random
like
you're an indiana nine uh they call it
they call it justin the thailand nine
say you got potential that's thailand
thailand
do you have some already some of the
submissions yeah i know we're here you
got something
oh dude has already sent it in
let's see look at brandon just making
himself look good you're cool
i didn't make that oh i have nothing to
do with that that's the way you guys
look
look like that anymore all right i'm
cutting my hair all right this is uh
adam del toro he does a lot of jiu jitsu
ventura i feel like i'm in la 4.5 4.5
he looks like marquez doesn't he the
boxer no we ever see marquez yeah
no he's looking like a little marcus
yeah that's something no absolutely not
well no you ever seen him chin
brilliant no not this dude i'm thinking
of someone else okay yeah
about to say brian yeah
he's only got in trouble for putting
cement in his wraps
oh he's talking about margaritos
okay okay oh yeah yeah we just don't
know our mexicans
man yeah he said he's something he
thinks he's a 4.5 you don't think he is
no what do you think he is i think he's
higher than five i give
that guy i need to see more of the bombs
you said he's i mean
without glasses he's better looking
justin
no you could play my homie bro look at
that bone structure look at the cheeks
go to chicken
[ __ ] justin got a he got cheeks
don't you ever play he got different
it's the dip i tell you i'd say he's a
six
he's a west side six side six he's an
east la
seven i got a west side six yeah okay
what else you got jeff all right
next one uh this one unfortunately no
name no
no like there's zero description on them
but this could be like a
uh they may not be catfishing yeah i was
about to say
well there's two pictures one of him and
his girl and wife and him dude them eyes
are ten i'll tell you oh yeah he's
smoking hot yes
i give him 8.5 he's an arkansas 9. oh
arkansas
arkansas 12. no i'd say arkansas is
[Applause]
ufc fan yeah bro guy
clean he's got so symmetrical everything
else is so symmetrical
it looks fake you got that mario like if
you use that filter where you flip the
face over it looks exactly the same
his eyes are gorgeous yeah
yes
on who's attending or bradley cooper
would be a tenant they live in los
angeles okay
okay those are tens walking in the
street you're telling me this a
good looking dude you're telling me he's
the equivalent of brad pitt
if you put him next to side by side of
bradley cooper i guarantee you he'll
hold
his own he hold it here hold his arm
brenda are you serious no yes
if a squadron girl see both of them oh
they both
going for both of them you just cause
he's bradley cooper has a name you're on
your mind
are you go to the other one to the other
one let me just see
i think it looks better in the first
picture personally but this is more real
the angle on the this picture is just a
little weird we know how he looks
now you know that oh 300 pounds yes
no i think you're pretty spot-on it's
not that the other guy isn't good
also bradley's 6-4
[ __ ] bona fide dime this guy can be
6-3 wait bradley cooper 6-4 yeah he's
big
really tall man i had no idea i didn't
know
the exception name of mark wahlberg
diesel's not tall mark wahlberg
diesel is uh six foot no he's not he's
not six foot no he's not i've seen him
in person not six foot okay
mark wahlberg short this one name
anybody yeah name another name besides
the rock who's big
yeah i feel like most actors are fairly
short and i see them on the carpet i
feel like you're like on the taller
spectrum
of yeah i've never seen like just tall
actors
no they're not big is chris hemsworth
that's all he's talking
about
what's the guy who plays the hulk he's
tall michael ruffalo mark ruffalo
buffalo yes mark ruffalo's
five eight no i've seen him in real life
he's five eight he's a little tall he's
he's tall to me no he's not tall
bro he was looking at a bet he's a five
eight and that's off wikipedia so he's
really
five seven five six are you serious
robert downey jr five
nine no one's huge yeah no one yet no
one saw him in real life or maybe i
still saw
no you don't know what you're talking
about oh keep going chin uh
all right this one you know the girl you
know who's super short
the dude who plays jon snow kate
harrington oh
mary's five
this is cass 24 year old 24 years old
from new york half asian half white
and her mirror is dirty that's the only
pink we got
i think there's another one oh she sent
us her instagram
yeah just those two pics
we get to write girls as well yeah
they're submitting you really hate dudes
no
that's what i thought the show was oh i
know she's cute she's cute
she's cute no i wish i saw him more
though i wish i saw more though and in
this picture she hides her face
like the first photo has a filter on it
you can tell she's cute but then
i need them to send like a regular so we
can go through any pics we want
[Music]
instagram handles um i'll give her seven
yeah she looks like la7 based off of
this seven i think she could be prettier
if i saw a regular photo i just need to
see more because it seems like a
snapchat we don't know if she has a gap
we don't know any of that so
la7 is kind of high yeah yeah you the la
7's high i agree
it's high l.a is hot you gave yourself a
la-6
yeah you see i'm saying you know l.a
y'all go to zoo culture all the time bro
you're gonna give that guy
a [ __ ] nothing and then this girl you
think of seven is dude
you guys are out of your [ __ ] mind we
don't have a segment
are you sticking on a segment you don't
hate him
let him go off cause i'm i'm dead what
are you you
you're saying we don't know if we should
have a gap let's assume that she has all
her appendages and not a gap
yeah i'm going over what i see right now
you don't give that a seven i mean bit
of a forehead
but still a seven you know
if you're gonna sign up for this spot
there's gonna be some shots listen
listen the two pictures
is the reason why i will not give thank
you we don't have enough information the
other guy only had two picks and one was
a shitty pick you give him a nine
that was not a shitty pig you said it
was a shitty piss no
because then you thank you that yeah so
you said it was a shitty pen yes and you
said you wanna judge me based off a
shitty pig i went he said sure
he said the angle no i said the angle oh
yeah you said that was bad
no look at her pick is her covering her
face taking a selfie in the mirror
i can't see anything you can't see
anything you can see her face and that
when you see the body in the other one
it's a filter on the first pick
it's a filter filter that is a filter
that's a filter
and you didn't even hear my rating
what's your already i know that when you
said 6.5
that's not bad yeah that's fair that's
true that's fine that's not bad so yeah
i think you're saying
you're going four no no she's not that
is not a four six or seven i'm fine with
yeah
i'm like well this one she's good like
the other one we can't even see it's a
bad picture
but listen that was the only one we were
fair with the first guy
east l.a seven uh you know what that was
one picture i gave him a 9.3
that guy yeah the first guy no the
second guy gave him nine oh the second
yeah the second guy yeah i'm sorry yeah
second guy
this guy right that guy you gave 9.3
yeah i feel like i can tell everyone's
biases already i feel like brendan and i
are more forgiving for girls and you
guys more forgiving for guys
that's what it is like no i'll fail
higher i'll tell
on the dudes they can handle a little
pete yeah girls come back
i was saying yes six point five is not
bad but i'm saying
you're gonna give her lower than i was
like no no
we almost should write them down ahead
of time because cat
she says seven and she and gave herself
a six i was like ain't no way
i said six or seven what cat's not a
narcissist she's not gonna give herself
a nine no no you can't have her in there
she's [ __ ] crazy
i know right yeah i got ten
[Laughter]
i said brad pitt or bradley cooper
but i'm saying the girl i just needed
more information i was going to go to
the next one
six or seven is fair okay six overall
score six and a half okay but we need
more
okay this is marcus 25 year old 25 years
old from rhode island
single no no i know right people say i
kind of like a skinny hold on let me let
me finish
skinny version of big brown himself i
feel like i'm a north east
how do i think i would handle the
midwest and cali
at the underscore marcus suggs on
instagram for more pictures to roast or
gas up that's him
okay okay you wanna so we gotta write
our rating now yeah oh this is about to
be fun okay write your ratings down and
then we will
he looks like a skinny andrew scholes
yeah that's a way better you don't look
like yeah
did it like luigi from super mario he
does look like luigi
okay la right l.a stanford strictly
ellie's dead
come on they don't pull up his problem
here's him with dyed hair oh he's tall
oh
charles this is la who is that guy he's
with right there i know that guy
uh should i do my hair button i don't
know should i dye my hair blonde again a
comment say hell no
hell no you look like uh that guy from
the stand eminem video
come on keep going where's a good one
with him flipping the camera off
there it is right there with the glasses
yeah let's analyze that one well you
look like a biker that never made it
super thin i don't like how you got his
thumbs when you flip people off
yeah it's like the weird weird one yeah
you gotta put you gotta put them in
thank you come on put them in if you got
weird thumbs put them in put them in
put them in okay i got it what do you
give them let's go with a
female's perspective i would give him an
la5
he has big dick energy i feel like he
does have big dick
turtle dactyl hanging between he has
that p davidson
like awkward big dick i'm gonna give him
a four or five well we gotta wait hold
on you gotta say
you gotta write it down you got right
now hold your card if you're a four odds
are you have a big dick okay so i gave
him i gave him all right chappelle hold
yours up
i'll get you i gave him a four i gave
him a four two la
four lay four la four okay yeah you're a
four okay
marcus that's an la-4 though dude so
it's la-4 good in long island you were
seven yeah nor northeast
you're killing like this oh you want to
kill him we gave our friend justin the
three
yeah yeah i just want to keep throwing
that out there
remember that he's a bonafide three yeah
remember that when you hear this sucks
all right who else we have uh this is
jim petty fresno california local
comedian
let's take a look what else did he say
thank you give me some more information
just don't skin by him
you know so thick very much so single
depends what day of the week it is
current rating fresno 10
firing kid rating question mark a little
mask off mask on
oh okay that's mask off
there's mask on so not much to go with
here
yeah that's it what's the point of mask
on
i think we're all on the same path yep
go ahead you ready yeah i give him a
three i got him oh i gave him a 3.5
that's fine that's fine i'll see you at
three la three
i gave him a three okay i don't know
there's something about like
him looking at that beer can and then
the next one he'll look at the camera
that like doesn't sit right with me
i don't know what it is it's like he's
hiding something he's hiding something i
can't i can feel it i just don't know
that snoop dogg hat is though i would
love to see an actual 10 submit a
picture
yeah some of them there's a 10 somewhere
out there
we've had a lot of three fours fives and
six yeah that's it
yeah i give a heart is that it we got
one more all right um
did you get mine here you go you want to
read this i'm a 44 year old colombian
don
diego living in the sixth toronto
father two awesome kids in their 20s
super fan of the pod
do amazing job always look forward to
the next episode happy easter and keep
it thick but aim for that rip
city all right here we go oh and he's a
papa
44 year old 44 years old dude but that
picture looks pretty old too that's only
one thing
only one picture you know you know 44
year olds don't know how to take
pictures right here's a
twin towers behind them
no it's that building drake is sitting
on yeah on the cover
the needle the tower the tower what's
his name
don don diego yeah i'm giving it i'm
assuming this is what he looks like
currently i'm giving him a nine
for whoa what father of two
two forty four what you guys oh that's
true
forty four forty three
i'm almost there and look at him father
of two and you got a four he's 20 year
olds yeah he's 20 year olds
running through this actually he's got
20 year olds yeah he's changing
20 year olds oh we got a factor today
okay cool i got him all right i'm good
now all right good all right
i gave him eight i gave him eight that's
wow
yeah that's a deal he's like built too
now
timeout we could use his instagram but
yeah because i see they didn't know
okay yeah now send in your instagram
handles please yeah please
yeah it helps us out make sure you're
counting private i know that's another
thing that
irritates me they'll send it in their
accounts private that's true
make it public make it public no it's
just so then you would have to go
through
your uh the photos that they gave you
like those are like their
ones yeah
another thing is you gotta send more
than one pick he's 44.
have at least one photo like you're
looking at the camera just like
you and your face not hiding really if
you're sending us your instagram we can
figure it out
and just even at that age he had he had
some
some kids man yeah you know that's true
i get it dude only one girl sent in i
know
that's the audience oh man it shocked me
that's why i was like we're writing
girls too i didn't know we had we'll get
more i'm sure
we mean no one talked about it earlier
yeah so just people just sent them in
they just sent to me that's jay's like
we're in a bunch of people asking to
rank them
i'm like all right that's funny that's
so funny ranked
this is just out of nowhere yeah well we
started ranking each other
but who does that yeah i don't think any
friend group i don't know too many
friend groups that rate each other
it's the first it's the first time i've
ever been rated by some homies of mine
and i didn't like it
yeah well you're not having fun that was
all brilliant
oh yeah you gave me i don't know how to
start exactly right you you said his
personality again
though people keep saying that to me
personality though that personality
though what
[Music]
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son